flying an airplane is one of the most
rewarding things that a person can do
but flying an airplane is nothing like
driving a car if you have car trouble
you can just pull off to the side of the
road you can't exactly do that in an
airplane because of that there are a few
things you should know as a pilot to
help you determine if your aircraft is
airworthy and safe for flight
[Music]
welcome to Free pilot training I'm Josh
and today I'm going to explain
everything you need to know as a pilot
when it comes to maintenance records and
inspections on an airplane now your
instructor is going to show you how to
do a good pre-flight inspection but in
this video I want to focus on the
aircraft logbooks and what you should be
looking for probably one of the most
important things that a pilot can do to
keep themselves and their passengers
safe is to do a thorough pre-flight
inspection on their aircraft in fact
according to far 91.7 the pilot in
command of a civil aircraft is
responsible for determining whether that
aircraft is in condition for safe flight
the pilot in command shall discontinue
the flight when unair worthy mechanical
electrical or structural conditions
occur
because of this it's important that you
learn to do a thorough walk around
inspection of the aircraft before you go
fly but there are a few things that you
can't really check during a walk around
how do I know that the engine is not
going to take a dump on me
[Music]
we all laugh at this but has the
aircraft been maintained or serviced
properly
has anyone looked inside of the Wings
lately to make sure that the wing spars
aren't getting rusty I mean that would
suck if the wings broke off on me when I
was out flying around but I would never
think to take off the wing panel and
look in there right before flying
there's just way too much stuff that
could go wrong with an airplane that's
why the FAA requires these things to be
maintained in a certain way and this
maintenance must be documented properly
so we know for sure that this thing is
airworthy well who's responsible for
making sure that this thing is
maintained properly according to far
91405 each owner or operator of an
aircraft has to make sure that all the
proper inspections are done on the
aircraft and if there's something wrong
they need to have the aircraft repaired
they must ensure that the maintenance
records are documented properly and
those records also indicate that the
aircraft can be returned to service if
there's a broken piece of equipment or a
broken instrument in the aircraft
there's some stuff that the owner or
operator needs to do before it can be
used again
now we're going to go into a lot more
detail on this stuff in just a minute
but first I got to know who is an
operator I know what an owner is that's
pretty obvious but this thing says that
the owner or the operator of an aircraft
is primarily responsible for maintaining
that aircraft in an airworthy condition
let's look at the definition of the word
operate in part one of the Federal
Aviation regulations
now I know that a lawyer wrote this
definition but basically it says that
operate means to use an aircraft or to
cause the use of an aircraft
if you are part of the crew of an
aircraft or you're the pilot in command
you are an operator of that aircraft
either you or the owner or both need to
make sure that the aircraft is
maintained properly both of you share
that responsibility if you know why
we're a good partnership for us
because we be watching watch out for one
another
like brothers and stuff so before we can
just jump in an airplane and go fly
there are two things we need to do to
make sure that it's completely airworthy
first you need to do a good pre-flight
inspection like we just discussed second
you need to make sure that the
maintenance records are up to date by
taking a good look at the aircraft's log
books now your instructor is going to
show you how to do a good pre-flight
inspection but in this video I want to
focus on the aircraft logbooks and what
you should be looking for and the first
step in doing that is to make sure that
all the inspections are done and that
they're documented properly if you're
looking for an easy way to remember all
these inspections a good acronym to use
is aviate and know that's not a typo the
letter i is supposed to be a one
as you can see the first inspection we
need to be concerned about as Pilots is
the annual inspection
for our 91409 is where you'll find the
requirements for this inspection but the
main thing you need to know is that the
annual inspection needs to be done every
12 calendar months that means that if
the inspection was done on April 10th
the next inspection is due on April 30th
12 months from that date I guess they do
this to give you a little time to get
that inspection done during the month
that it's due anyways if the airplane
has not had its annual inspection done
in the last 12 calendar months you
cannot legally fly it but once the
inspection has been completed the
mechanic needs to document that properly
in the aircraft logbooks and then you're
good to go now notice how I said that
the inspection needs to be documented
properly this is extremely important and
most amp mechanics are going to do a
good job of documenting their work but
remember as the operator you're also
responsible to make sure that this is
done correctly so let's take a look at
what needs to be written in the logbooks
when an inspection's been done you'll
find this information in far 91417 but
before I give you the general gist of
this document I want to read the first
couple sentences in here except for work
performed in accordance with 91411 and
91413 each registered owner or operator
shall keep the following records for the
period specified in paragraph B of this
section
records of the maintenance preventative
maintenance and alteration and records
of the hundred hour annual Progressive
and other required or approved
inspections as appropriate for each
aircraft including the airframe and each
engine rotor and Appliance of the
aircraft
okay so basically anytime anyone does
anything to the aircraft engine prop or
any other part of the airplane we need
to document that in the logbook I'm
going to talk about some of this other
stuff here in just a minute but as you
can see the annual inspection is another
time where we need to make sure that the
work has been documented properly so
let's look at what this entry in the
logbook needs to say in order to be
legal first there must be a description
of the work that was accomplished if an
annual inspection was completed it needs
to say that along with everything that
was done to the aircraft
second it needs to have the date of
completion so if our annual inspection
was done on April 10 2023 that needs to
be clearly marked in here so anyone who
looks at this knows that the next annual
is due on April 30th of 2024. next the
entry needs to have the signature and
the certificate number of the person
approving the aircraft for return to
service so we need to know who did this
inspection and their certificate number
because not just anyone can do annual
inspections it has to be a mechanic who
holds an IA or inspection authorization
so these are the things we have to have
any time any maintenance is done on the
aircraft including the annual inspection
but we're also required to keep a record
of a few things on the aircraft and the
best time to record those things is
either during the 100 hour or the annual
inspection so let's take a quick look at
those So based on my understanding these
things aren't really required during an
annual inspection but a good AirPlay
mechanic is going to include these with
its annual or as 100 hour inspection
because it's required to be documented
regularly in the log books the first
thing that's required to be documented
is the total time in service on the
airframe engine propeller and rotor if
it's a helicopter in addition to that
this also needs to include the current
status of the life limited parts on the
airframe and on each engine every
propeller rotor and Appliance in other
words if the magnetos are required to be
replaced every 500 hours then you would
need to document that in here so we know
when to replace those the next thing
that needs to be documented is the time
since last overhaul on all items
installed on the aircraft which are
required to be overhauled on a specified
time basis now a bunch of stuff can fall
into this category but the main thing
we're concerned about here is the engine
every engine is a little bit different
but this Cessna 172h has a continental
o300 in it and the manufacturer
recommends that you have this engine
overhauled every 1800 hours so to let us
know how long it's been since this
thing's been overhauled you typically
see an acronym like this and this stands
for time sense overhaul or this one
right here which stands for time since
major overhaul
there are a few more things you could
see in here instead but these are
usually the standard so if I look in the
logbook and see that this thing says 1
820 hours time since major overhaul that
means this thing is a timed out engine
now it's important to keep in mind that
many of these overhaul periods are
manufacturer recommendations so in most
cases you could legally fly the aircraft
pass overhaul but if you do this you
really want to know for sure that this
engine has been well maintained I
actually discussed this quite a bit in
my video with Seth Lake where we talked
about seven things you should know
before buying an airplane so if you want
more information on that you should
really check that video out anyway
another requirement is that you document
the inspection status of the aircraft
this is another reason why a good IA is
going to document all this stuff with
the annual all this stuff is required to
be documented anyways you might as well
document that at the same time
okay the next thing that needs to be
documented in here is the current status
of the applicable airworthiness
directives
now I'm going to go into a lot more
detail on this here in just a minute but
once again a good IA is going to make
sure that the airworthiness directives
are all current and up to date and that
they are documented properly when they
do the annual inspection last but not
least if the airplane has had a major
alteration on the airframe on any
current installed engine propeller rotor
or Appliance there's some specific forms
that need to go into the aircraft log
books if that happens now this raises an
interesting point because the engine
propeller and appliances can be removed
from the airframe and swapped out for
other parts as long as it's done by an
approved mechanic because of this most
aircraft will have separate log books
for the airframe the engine and the
propellers that allows the mechanic to
document all this stuff for each of
these items then if you decide to
upgrade your engine at a later time and
you sell the old one to another person
then they can have the complete history
of that engine and that makes the engine
you're selling much more valuable
inspection that's required if you're
going to be operating an aircraft for
higher according to 91 409b if you're
going to be carrying any person for hire
or if the aircraft is being used for
flight instruction for hire the aircraft
needs to have a 100 hour inspection done
within the last hundred hours of service
now if you're watching this video while
you're working on your private pilot's
license this inspection still applies to
you if you're receiving flight
instruction for hire if you're getting
your flight instruction from your buddy
for free in your own personal airplane
then this inspection doesn't apply to
you now here's something kind of
interesting about the 100 hour
inspection notice here that it says no
person may operate in aircraft carrying
any person other than a crew member for
hire and no person may give flight
instruction for hire in an aircraft
which that person provides unless within
the preceding hundred hours of time and
service the aircraft has received an
annual or a hundred hour inspection and
been approved for return to service blah
blah blah this means that if an annual
inspection has been done in the last
hundred hours the annual inspection can
take the place of a 100 hour inspection
however a 100 hour inspection cannot
take the place of an annual inspection
this is because there are a few more
things that need to be checked on an
annual inspection that is not covered on
the hundred hour I've actually seen some
schools that only perform annual
inspections so you never see the 100
inspection documented anywhere in that
case you would just have to look in the
logbook at the hours on the aircraft at
the time of the annual inspection to
know whether or not you're legal for the
100 hour requirement
okay so how do I know that my aircraft
is due for a hundred hour inspection
well first you need to look at the
logbook like I just mentioned let's say
that the company that's renting this
airplane to you is doing normal 100 hour
inspections and the last documented
inspection was done at 2
252.9 hours when is a 100 hour
inspection due on this aircraft if you
said
2352.9 hours I want to congratulate you
on your math skills but which one of
these hour gauges do I use the Hobbs or
the attack time
is this thing do its 100 hour inspection
or not well the Hobbs time is used to
calculate the time that the aircraft is
in use and that should be used to
calculate the time in your logbook but
when it comes to maintenance you need to
use the TAC time in other words the time
you see on the tachometer so yes this
airplane is due for its 100 hour
inspection and it cannot be operated for
a higher unless we get that done
now 91409 does allow us to go over this
time if we absolutely need to and one
reason why we might need to do that is
to fly the aircraft to a place where the
inspection can be accomplished maybe
there's no amp mechanic on the field in
that case the airplane can be flown up
to but no more than 10 hours past the
100 hour inspection time with that in
mind you can't just go fly around
wherever you want for those 10 hours
past the 100 hour inspection they only
allow you to go past the 100 hours for
the specific purpose of getting the
inspection done and if you do fly past
that hundred hour mark the next 100 hour
inspection is due 100 hours from the
time the original inspection was due if
you fly two hours over you don't get two
free hours so if the inspection was due
at 2
352.9 hours and you flew at 2 354.9
hours to get it inspected the next
hundred hour inspection is still due at
452.9 hours I'm sure they do that to
keep people from working the system and
always going 110 hours before getting
the inspection done
[Applause]
[Music]
Lisa I want some more
please sir
I want some
more
now according to far91409 not all
aircraft are required to have the annual
or the 100 hour inspection these
inspections do not apply to an aircraft
that carries a special flight permit a
current experimental certificate or a
light sport or provisional airworth in a
certificate a special flight permit is
basically a ferry permit you can request
these from the FAA if you buy an
airplane that's out of its annual or 100
hour inspection and you need to fly it
somewhere where you can get that
inspection done experimental aircraft
and light sport aircraft are not
required to have the annual or 100 hour
inspection done either
and experimental aircraft is basically a
kit plane or a homemade aircraft someday
I'm going to build one of these maybe
the Vans company will send me an rv15 to
test out on my adventurement channel
anyway experimental and light sport
aircraft have some slightly different
maintenance requirements instead of an
annual they have to get something called
an annual condition inspection my
understanding is that it's not quite as
intense but I really don't know that
much about those but I do know that this
condition inspection still has to be
documented in the aircraft logbooks okay
let's take a look at the next inspection
in our Ada acronym the altimeter
inspection you'll find this requirement
in far 91411 and what you'll find in
here is that no person may operate an
airplane or helicopter in controlled
airspace under IFR unless within the
preceding 24 calendar months each static
pressure system each altimeter
instrument and each automatic pressure
altitude reporting system has been
tested and inspected and found to comply
with these other document now I know
that most of you guys watching this
video are working on your PPL and you
don't even want to think about
instrument stuff yet but this is one of
an examiner's favorite questions when is
the altimeter inspection due and this
question comes up because according to
91205 the altimeter is required for VFR
flight but oddly enough the inspection
is not you only need to have that
inspection if you're operating under IFR
in controlled airspace and that
inspection is done every 24 calendar
months now I'll go into more detail on
this when I start working on my
Instrument series but as you may have
noticed not only does the altimeter need
to be inspected but so does the whole
entire pedo static system along with
each automatic pressure altitude
reporting system if you're going to be
operating under IFR that's all you need
to know about the altimeter inspection
for now so let's move on and talk about
the T in our AB8 acronym the transponder
inspection now another reason why I
mentioned the altimeter inspection is
because that inspection is often
performed and documented at the same
time time as the transponder inspection
and the transponder is also required to
be inspected every 24 calendar months
but unlike the altimeter inspection this
is an inspection that concerns you
because according to far 91413 you
cannot legally use your transponder
unless it has had a passing inspection
within the last 24 calendar months now
it doesn't say you can't fly you just
can't use your transponder well what
does that mean that means you cannot fly
into certain airspace because you
legally need to turn the transponder off
according to 91413 now I don't really
agree with this reg because I think if
you're operating in airspace where the
transponder is not required I believe
that it's safer to have that thing
turned on but technically you're not
supposed to use it at all a manual don't
do it Emmanuel don't do it manual so if
we haven't had the transponder
inspection done where can we fly you may
remember talking about this in past
episodes but the answer to that is in
91-15 now things do start to get a
little confusing in this rig because
there are a few different types of
transponders but the thing to remember
is that these things allow ATC to pick
you up on radar more easily so they
essentially make the aircraft's radar
signature stronger so they can see you
better now there are two types of
transponders that you're allowed to use
the most common type in GA aircraft is
the 4096 transponder but a mode s
transponder works as well both of these
types of transponders respond to mode 3A
interrogations from ATC
but in addition to that your transponder
also needs to have something called mode
C capability and all mode C does is it
reports your pressure altitude to ATC
anyway if we haven't had the 24 calendar
month inspection that means we cannot
use either one of these transponders
because of that we can't legally fly in
class A airspace Class B airspace the
mode C veil of Class B airspace Class C
airspace you can't even Fly Above Class
B or C airspace in fact you can't fly
anywhere above 10 000 feet MSL unless
you're flying below 2500 feet AGL but as
you can see if you go past the 24 month
inspection this can really limit you on
where you can go fly and if you aren't
paying attention to the maintenance
records on the airplane this rule is a
really easy one to accidentally break so
keep an eye on that it's a pretty simple
inspection the mechanic just has to run
a few tests to make sure that everything
is working the way it should and the
transponder is responding properly to
atc's interrogations
now the enr aviate acronym stands for
the elt inspection and I talked about
that quite a bit in my last video but
let's take a look at a couple things
really quick the elt has its own
regulation for 91207 and what you'll
find in here is that the elt needs to be
inspected every 12 calendar months
because of that the elt is almost always
inspected during the annual inspection
if it's not make sure you're paying
attention to where that's being
documented in the aircraft logbooks
because this is another one that's easy
to forget
during its annual inspection the elt
gets checked for a few things the
mechanic checks to make sure that it's
installed properly he checks to make
sure that there's no battery corrosion
and he also checks the operation of the
controls and the Crash sensor and make
sure that it's sending out a good signal
as you may remember the elt is a
required piece of equipment and you want
to make sure that that thing is working
properly in case you ever need it so
making sure that the inspection is done
is an important part of making sure that
your aircraft is air worthy okay I've
had just about enough talking about
inspections let's move on and talk about
everyone's favorite airworthiness
directives
right now you might be wondering what
the hex an airworthiness directive and
the easiest way to explain this is that
it's kind of like a product recall that
sometimes happens to specific Parts on
an airplane
now as I say every regulation that was
ever made Was Written in Blood and
airworthiness directives are so
important that they actually get their
own regulation over in part 39 but the
main thing you need to know is that the
faa's airworthiness directives are
legally enforceable rules that apply to
the following products aircraft aircraft
engines propellers and appliances
now the FAA issues an airworthiness
directive or ad on one of these products
if they feel that an unsafe condition
exists on a specific product on the
aircraft and the condition is likely to
exist or develop in other products of
the same design
let's take a look at one of the most
famous ads that affect a huge part of
the Cessna Fleet including Cessna 172s
The Story Goes Like This apparently some
guy was out doing stalls in a system 172
and while he happened to have the nose
of the aircraft pitch way up the little
latching mechanism that held the seat in
place got worn out because of that the
sea slipped off the back of the tracks
and this made the pilot to where he
could no longer reach the controls
apparently when this happened he lost
control of the aircraft then spun to a
fiery death
well as you can imagine this started
getting a lot of attention so what the
FAA do that's right they started looking
at these seat rails and then they
realized that these weren't exactly the
safest design and then they created an
airworthiness directive to keep this
from happening to other aircraft once
again these ads are legally enforceable
and that means that they're mandatory
and you have to comply with these and
document that they've been done and just
like all the other maintenance on the
aircraft the owner or the operator is
responsible to make sure that these have
been done and documented in the log
books that's why you need to know this
stuff because you're going to be
operating an aircraft anytime you go fly
it now here's an interesting question
when an ad comes out is the aircraft
immediately grounded it can be in some
cases but in most cases the FAA gives
you a little bit of time to get that
done let's take a closer look at this
seat rail ad here at the top we have the
airworthiness directive number then you
can see here that this one is effective
as of June 17 2011.
now this ad actually supersedes an older
one from 1987 and that's important to
know because that original directive no
longer applies to our aircraft
now this thing basically tells us all
the different aircraft models that it
applies to and as you can see this
applies to a ton of different Cessna
models down here we start getting into
the meat and potatoes they give us a
brief synopsis of the unsafe condition
then down here it tells us actually what
needs to be done
if you take the time to read this thing
you'll notice that this ad is basically
an inspection that needs to be done
every 100 hours or every 12 calendar
months whichever comes first and when
this requirement first came out the
owner or operator had 100 hours or 12
calendar months to get that first
inspection done
so yes sometimes ads will require
something to be done immediately if the
FAA thinks that it's a big enough
problem but usually you have a little
bit of time now this particular ad is a
reoccurring inspection and the FAA was
nice enough to line it up with the
annual inspection so this ad should be
accomplished and documented every annual
or 100 hour inspection but not all ads
are reoccurring and not all of them are
inspections some of them require you to
change a part one time and that's it and
some require something to be inspected
one time and that's it in that case this
needs to be documented in the aircraft
logbooks so whoever's flying the
aircraft can easily access it so they
know for sure that this thing's
airworthy right now I can see that I
just scared the crap out of everyone
watching this video and now you might be
thinking you don't want to be a pilot
anymore but this isn't quite as bad as
you think if you have a good amp
mechanic he's going to do most of the
legwork on these things he's going to
make sure that they're complied with and
he's also going to make sure that
they're documented properly the hardest
part about airworthiness directives is
finding out which ones are applicable to
your aircraft and the reason for this is
because the air airframe is not the only
part of an aircraft that can have 80s
against it there can be ads against the
engine propeller and basically any
Appliance installed on the aircraft no
I'm not talking about a microwave or
refrigerator I'm talking about things
like the magnetos the carburetor and
other stuff like that
so yes you can go out to your plane and
make a list of all the equipment
installed on your aircraft and then you
could look up all this stuff in the
faa's dynamic regulatory system and then
check the logbook to see if all these
things were done but a good ANP mechanic
has specific software to look all this
stuff up he can also look through the
logbook at each one of these ads to make
sure that they've been accomplished then
print out a nice neat document that
shows you each airworthiness directive
number what the 80s for when it was
accomplished how it was complied with if
it's a reoccurring ad when the next due
date is if it is reoccurring and who
accomplished it now I actually made a
video with Seth Lake over at vsl
Aviation that goes into a lot more
detail on this so if you want more
information on ads you should definitely
go check that out but the big thing you
need to know is that according to far
91417 one of the records that are
required to be with the aircraft is the
current status of the applicable ads so
yes your amp buddy could look at each
one of these individually and just write
the words all applicable airworthiness
directives complied with but if I see
that I'm not really so sure that they
have been accomplished it's a lot more
comforting that my aircraft really isn't
an airworthy condition if I can look at
something like this and know for sure I
okay we're done talking about your
worthiness directives now you can
uncover your eyes let's move on and talk
a little bit about alterations and
repairs to the aircraft as you continue
to fly you'll likely run into an issue
on your aircraft that requires a repair
you might also find something that you'd
like to change or alter on your aircraft
but before you do either one of these
things there's something really
important to consider
as you may remember the aircraft we fly
usually needs to be certified in a
certain operating category for example
your training aircraft is likely
certified in the normal and possibly
even in the utility category
but if you start making alterations or
repairs to that aircraft that can change
the way that the airplane flies and this
can cause some serious problems for
example if you start messing around with
the flight controls too much and you
make some kind of alteration on those
you could potentially change the center
of gravity envelope for your aircraft
maybe the fcg limit used to be here but
whatever you did moved it right here
anyone that's flying the aircraft is
trusting this weight and balance chart
because the aircraft is certified to fly
in this entire envelope but because you
made that change I could potentially get
myself in a dangerous situation if I'm
operating back here because I think it's
safe because of that when an aircraft is
repaired or altered by someone it needs
to be done so by someone who knows what
they're doing and is certified to do
that work in addition to that if there's
a major alteration or repair on that
aircraft it must be test flown now 91407
gives you some more specific details on
this requirement but what you'll find
here is that one the person who does the
work needs to be properly certified then
two the aircraft cannot carry any
passengers until it's been properly test
flown
oddly enough this test can be done with
someone that has a Private Pilot
certificate just be careful about this
though are you an expert on weight and
balance or aircraft performance most
private Pilots are not this caveat was
really made for certified mechanics who
know what they're doing and can test the
aircraft once they're done with the work
but I guess if you want you can legally
perform the flight test just make sure
that it's documented properly in the
forms and the aircraft is approved for
return to service by the mechanic here's
where we can start getting into the
weeds but I want to mention this because
I think it's important for understanding
what you can do to your aircraft the
things that you can do to a certified
aircraft are very limited yes the
mechanic can make minimal alterations to
a certified aircraft but if you want to
modify your aircraft in any way that
needs to go through an approval process
this is what we call a supplemental type
certificate or STC here's a quick
example this aircraft was originally
built with a Lycoming 0320 engine and
this guy's rated for 150 horsepower
maybe I want a little bit more juice so
I buy an o360 that has 180 hush puppies
yes newer system 172s are often built
with the o360 in them and they come
certified from the factory that way but
if I want to get that installed on my
Cessna 172i I've got to get a
supplemental type certificate for that
you might be thinking why would you need
to do that and the reason is because
that aircraft was certified with a
smaller engine and there's a bunch of
stuff that's going to change if I get
that installed and all that needs to be
added to my poh to make sure that we're
operating with the most current and
accurate data for flight with that in
mind you can perform some maintenance on
your aircraft as long as it's not major
maintenance you as an owner can only
perform preventative maintenance part 43
of the Federal Aviation regulations is
where you'll find more details on this
and over in appendix a what you'll find
is the exact definition of major
alterations major repairs and
preventative maintenance and down in the
preventative maintenance section the FAA
actually tells you all the stuff you can
work on yourself as long as it doesn't
involve complex assembly operations
a few things you can do
you can change out or repair the landing
gear tires you can service the wheel
bearings on the landing gear you can
refill the hydraulic fluid reservoir you
can do some upholstery work if you're
into that and you can even replace the
side windows as long as they don't
interfere with the structure of the
aircraft or any operating system
now there's a bunch more stuff in here
but as you can see these things are
really simple maintenance items that
keep the aircraft in good operating
condition so once again you're limited
to preventative maintenance and you can
change out some small parts on the
aircraft as long as it's not too
complicated now the reg that actually
allows you to do preventative
maintenance is far 43.3 G and as you can
see as long as you have a pilot
certificate issued under part 61 both an
owner and an operator can do
preventative maintenance but only a
Certified mechanic can return the
aircraft to service if the aircraft is
being repaired or serviced for something
other than preventative maintenance but
if you do change the oil or if you do
any of these preventative items don't
forget to document that properly in the
logbook remember 91417 says that there's
four things we need to document when we
do that a description of the work that
was done the date of completion the
signature of who did the work and the
certificate number of the person who
approves the aircraft to be returned to
service remember even though it's
preventative maintenance it's super
important that you document everything
you do to the aircraft that lets
everyone know for sure that this thing
is an airworthy condition and we don't
have anything to worry about now who can
return an aircraft to service according
to 43.7 you have to have at least a PPL
to be able to return an aircraft to
service after performing preventative
maintenance I guess I figured private
parts are responsible enough to remember
putting oil back in after they've
drained the old stuff and replace the
filter
okay but what if I go out to the
airplane and I do a pre-flight
inspection and something's broken what
now can I go fly let's say you're
getting ready to do the walk around and
you turn the master power switch on
what's usually one of the first things
you hear when you turn this thing on
well you typically hear one of the Gyros
spin up don't you
let's say you turn the master on and you
didn't hear anything now what what's
broken can we legally go fly well as you
may remember most training aircraft with
an analog cockpit only have one
electrically driven gyroscopic
instrument that's usually the turn and
slip indicator remember the attitude and
heading indicator are usually vacuum
driven so we've got a problem with the
turn and slip indicator can we legally
go fly if so what do we need to do
well according to 91 213 no person may
take off an aircraft with inoperative
instruments or equipment installed
unless a few conditions are met now
there's a lot of information in this rig
but what you'll find is that there are
basically two different ways you can
determine whether or not you can legally
fly without a certain instrument or
piece of equipment first is with an Mel
or minimum equipment list and the second
is by using far 91213d
now most of you guys are going to be
using far 91 213 section D because mels
are typically for larger turbine-powered
aircraft but there are some smaller
multi-engine aircraft that can have them
as well so we'll briefly discuss that
here in just a minute but for now let's
focus on 91 213 because if you have an
inoperative piece of equipment you need
to follow this rig to the letter if you
don't you could fail your check ride if
you have something broken and you
haven't done any of this stuff you can
even get yourself into trouble after you
get your license as well but anyway
91213d says that if we have inoperative
equipment we can still take off if the
inoperative instruments and Equipment
are not part of the VFR day type
certification instruments and Equipment
prescribed in the applicable
airworthiness regulations under which
the aircraft was type certified remember
how I said that we're operating
certified aircraft well when the
aircraft was certified there are some
pieces of equipment that are often
installed on the aircraft that allow
them to meet the requirements of a
certain category a good example of this
would be a stall fence that you
sometimes see on the upper surface of a
wing you can't just take that thing off
because you think it looks stupid or you
hit a bird and it got damaged that thing
was most likely installed specifically
to get that airplane into its certified
category notice here that this Cessna
172 Sierra poh has something called the
comprehensive equipment list as you can
see here it's specifically lists items
that are required required to meet the
FAA certification requirements it looks
like if there's an R next to something
that means the FAA requires it for
certification
as you can see this placard with the
operational limits is a required piece
of equipment but if we move down the
page and find the turn coordinator on
here that's only a standard piece of
equipment and it's not actually required
now there are a lot of different ways a
manufacturer can list the required
equipment on an aircraft some of the
older aircraft might just have notes
throughout the flight manual and on
newer aircraft you'll often see a list
like I just showed you but something
we're starting to see more and more of
in newer aircraft is something called
the kinds of operations equipment list
or koel
if your airplane has one of these you
are required to use it now we're looking
at a poh from a newer Cessna 172 Sierra
with a G1000 in it and as you can see
this koel is pretty easy to use all you
have to do is find the piece of
equipment that's inoperative over here
then find the line that shows the kind
of operation that you're going to be
flying under
if I'm flying under vf4 during the day
as you can see Zero Turn coordinators
are required on board the aircraft if
I'm going to be operating VFR at night
then I don't have to have one for that
either but the second I want to operate
under IFR I've got to have at least one
turn coordinator working next the
inoperative equipment cannot be required
by far 91 205. ah good old 91 205 it
keeps coming back up for some reason it
seems like in almost every lesson I
wonder if you're going to see this
regulation on your check ride
okay so once again we've got the minimum
day VFR required items then we have the
minimum night VFR required items then we
have the required IFR stuff
now we said that our turn and slip
indicator was broken existing required
for day VFR operations no it's not but
what if my airspeed indicator was broken
can I still go fly no I can't as you can
see that's a required piece of equipment
so as of right now it's looking like we
might be able to go fly today but we've
got a few more things to look at and do
first
so you're telling me there's a chance
yeah the last thing we need to do is to
check the airworthiness directives is
this thing required by an airworthiness
directive this is another reason why you
need to be familiar with the
airworthiness directives on your
aircraft now there isn't an ad for this
particular aircraft for the turn and
slip indicator but take a look at this
placard on the fuel selector valve on
the Cessna 172h this is a piece of
equipment that is required to be
installed by an airworthiness directive
and if you did have an ad that required
you to have a turn and slip indicator
then you cannot go fly unless you get
that thing fixed okay it looks like the
turn and slip indicator is not required
but there's one more thing we got to do
we either need to remove it or
deactivate it the first thing we could
do is to remove it from the aircraft
then we could put a placard on it that
says we removed it on purpose and then
we could document it in the log books
another option is to deactivate the item
then put a placard over the top of it
that says inoperative now to properly
deactivate this thing all you need to do
is pull the circuit breaker for it if
there's not a circuit breaker it should
really be deactivated by an amp mechanic
or certified avionics guy and the same
thing goes for removing the item you
can't just pull that thing out yourself
because it doesn't work because you
could potentially mess something up and
in some cases the aircraft might need to
be reweighed for Weight and Balance
purposes
once again don't forget to update your
logbook if you do this okay let's talk
about Mel's or minimum equipment list
for just a minute once again mels are
usually found on turbine-powered
aircraft but some smaller multis can
have them as well the way these work is
very similar to the koel we talked about
earlier but the FAA has created a basic
Mel for most larger aircraft and if you
have an aircraft that needs an Mel you
take that basic Mel then you look at the
specific equipment that's installed on
your aircraft and then you can create a
custom minimum equipment list for that
specific aircraft
once that's complete you have to send
that up to the fsdo or the flight
standards district office and they will
either approve it or disapprove it and
once this guy's approved it's a required
item that must be on board the aircraft
when it flies it's like a part of the
poh and that particular Mel needs to
stay with that specific aircraft you
can't swap emels if you have multiple
aircraft anyway once this thing is
approved you can use this guy instead of
91 213d but if you do you have to follow
the procedures in there very carefully
this is a page from an Mel for a
Beechcraft 400. let's say my autopilot
quit working and I want to go fly to get
a thousand dollar Hamburger because
let's be realistic that's what's going
to cost you if you fly the same all I
need to do is go down this list and find
my inoperative piece of equipment on
here as you can see there's one
autopilot installed on this aircraft
then over here it tells me how many are
required looks like I don't need no
stink in autopilot but I'm not quite
done yet there's some remarks over here
it says maybe an operative provided it's
deactivated approach minimums or enrue
operations do not require its use the
rudder boost is operative yeah you
definitely want that in case you lose an
engine then it looks like I can't go up
into rvsm airspace
in addition to that you probably noticed
this little repair category that just
lets you know how long you can use this
thing before you have to get it fixed
and there should be a chart somewhere in
the Mel that tells you how long you can
fly the aircraft before you have to take
it somewhere and get that fixed one last
thing I want to mention about the Mel is
that if your aircraft has an Mel you
have to use it you can't just decide
that 91 213 is less restrictive so I'm
just going to throw the Mel out the
window nope you can't do that
thanks for joining me today on free
pilot training I know this is a really
tough lesson today but it's also a
really important lesson if you want to
be 100 sure that your aircraft is safe
and 100 airworthy when you take your
family out for that thousand dollar
hamburger in my next video I'm going to
go into detail on everything you need to
know about nodems and the chart
supplement when that video is done I'll
put it right here
see it